GIVE LAVISH GIFTS TO HIS MOST
VALUABLE SCENES.
WE'RE THE FIRST FOREIGN
IMMEDIATE YO TO COME ABOVE THE
RAINBOW, FOUR STORIES, EIGHT
RESTAURANTS, 11,000 SQUARE
METERS FLOATING ON THE RIVER.
SUPREME LEADER KIM JONG UN'S
FIELD INSPECTION, A LEAD STORY
ON STATE CONTROLLED MEDIA.
THE ANNOUNCER CALLING IT A GIFT
TO THE PEOPLE.
THIS IS WHERE THE LEADER SAT?
AT THE REVOLVING RESTAURANT AND
OTHERS INSPECTED BY THE LEADER,
YOU CAN PROBABLY GUESS THE MOST
COVETED SEATS.
WHAT DO YOUR CUSTOMERS SAY TO
SIT HERE?
LANK.
>> EVERY WANTS TO SIT HERE.
THEY RUSH TO GRAB IT.
THE RAINBOW SEEN CAPACITY
CROWDS.
2,000 PEOPLE IN THE FIRST HOUR.
FACTORY WORKER BROUGHT HIS WHOLE
FAMILY.
IS THIS AFFORDABLE FOR EVERYDAY
PEOPLE HERE IN NORTH KOREA?
ANYONE CAN COME HERE, IT'S MEANT
FOR ALL PEOPLE HE SAYS.
MENU ITEMS RUN FROM A FEW U.S.
CENTS TO A FEW DOLLARS.
IT'S HARD TO CALCULATIONS
EXACTLY HOW MUCH THE NORTH
KOREAN EARNS, SOME ESTIMATES SAY
AN ENTIRE FAMILY MIGHT BRING IN
$100 A MONTH.
HOUSING, HEALTHCARE, FOOD
RATIONS AND OTHER SERVICES FREE
FROM THE STATE.
VIRTUALLY NOBODY OWNS A CAR BUT
CAN PAY UP TO $2 PER RIDE AT THE
AMUSEMENT PARK.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
>> I'M SO HAPPY TO WATCH MY
DAUGHTER ON THE RIDE SAYS THIS
GRANDMOTHER.
HER FAMILY AMONG 3,000 PEOPLE AT
THE PARK CONSIDERED A BUSY
NIGHT.
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
>> I'VE TRIED ALL THE RIDES SAYS
HER DAUGHTER.
THIS ONE IS MY FAVORITE.
SOME MAY CONSIDER THIS AN ODD
INVESTMENT FOR A NATION WITH
REGULAR FOOD AND ELECTRICITY
SHORTAGES.
BUT IT'S PART OF A PROMISE BY
THE REGIME TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S
LIVING STANDARDS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT LIFE IS LIKE
IN PARTS OF NORTH KOREA WE'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO VISIT.
DEFECTORS AND AID WORKERS PAINT
A FAR DARKER PICTURE THAN THESE
SPARKLING LIGHTS BUT HERE IN THE
CAPITAL, MORE NEW AMENITIES EACH
YE